allegations of improper sexual behavior
are sparking investigations into a pair
of first term freshmen members of
Congress up on Capitol Hill
of course Ponte Ellison barber tells us
who's involved two lawmakers are now
being investigated by the House Ethics
Committee accused of having sexual
relationships with individuals on their
congressional staff Representative
Michael San Nicolas a non-voting
delegate representing Guam and
Representative Katie Hill both are
freshmen Democrats Hill is one of the
most powerful freshman members the Los
Angeles Times once described her as
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi s new
favorite but today the young Democrat is
dealing with a barrage of accusations
involving her personal life in a letter
obtained by Fox News he'll apologize to
her constituents for having an
inappropriate relationship with the
subordinate on her campaign but denied
having an affair with a congressional
staffer the latter is the allegation
that triggered the ethics probe an if
true would violate House Rules Hill says
she is quote going through a divorce
from an abusive husband determined to
humiliate her
she says all of this is part of a smear
campaign and she is cooperating with the
ethics committee Democrats are largely
remaining mom we had a caucus meeting it
didn't come up I'm not familiar with the
nature of the allegations but Hill is
getting support from an unlikely source
Republican representative Matt gates who
among us would look perfect if every ex
leaked every photo / text the Trump ally
tweeted Katie isn't being investigated
by ethics or maligned because she hurt
anyone it is because she is different
Hill identifies as bisexual she was
noticeably absent from the halls of
Congress today and despite serving as
the vice chair of the Oversight
Committee did not appear to attend
services for the late chairman Elijah
Cummings a nude photo was published on
the blog that first reported the
allegations Hill said she contacted
Capitol police about that photo
additional photos and allegations have
since been reported but Fox News has not
been able to independently verify them
right Allison thank you